bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est au
mobile world congress sur le stand de la
prime time business france avec javier
bonjour qui est business france en
espagne
exactement je suis conseiller export
senior pour les affronte l'espagne et je
crains c'est seulement live pour la cité
pouvoir business france
organisé e
cette édition
[Musique]
vous êtes là depuis combien de lits de
soins deuxième 12e quoi alors qu'est ce
qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que business
france la french state apporte aux start
up qui serait présente sur ce salon
c'est un salon professionnel on n'est
pas sur un salon grand public
qu'est ce que ça doit vraiment apporté
puisqu'elle est un peu la psychologie
d'entreprise qu'on a trouvé ici
exactement alors ici on est sur un salon
sur les télécommunications au sens large
on parle aussi d'audiovisuel on parle
aussi de à
on parle de guy santé disant anti mais
bien les grands le corps du business
elle quelques lobbies de france
a accompagné son entreprise
et quelque chose
sur deux de hall 5 8 dont lui depuis
spécialisé sur les gars des techno ou de
différent
secteur dans la télécommunication du
hardware software et c'est avec très
très déçu
et qui ont remporté pas mal de prix et
on a une vingtaine d'experts de
différents continents différents pays
qui viennent à apporter leur soutien
et organiser des rendez vous réguliers
qualifier
on a organisé le 5 sans rendez vous
ça rendez vous pendant quinze jours
exactement machine de guerre c'est
énorme
exactement et
le but ici c'est que nos frères fasse un
peu un teasing
on aide les entreprises
avoir le coup de talent et à l'étranger
et leur dire voilà de leur offrir un peu
leurs portes l'opportuniste certains
marchés
cette fois en amérique pouvoir en europe
moi on a pris ou en lin vu ça veut dire
que les entreprises seront présentes ici
viennent chercher des marchés pour
travailler avec des pros pour développer
leurs activités
on n'est pas vraiment sûr pas du tout
solutions grand public joie cardiaque
note que je connais j'ai déjà rencontré
qui elle est plus dédié au grand public
sur une solution de jeux connectées jeux
vidéo en ligne un peu à la netflix
exactement mise à part cette entreprise
qui on peut retrouver qui avait vraiment
envie qu'ils pourraient plus parler au
grand public
exactement alors on a des entreprises
qu'ils se font du pitou be well as
business to business s'adresse à lui le
grand public ont trouvé ce que tu viens
de citer exactement c'est une entreprise
et to be to see
au final elle vient chercher des grands
comptes comme telefonica par exemple
comme du vodafone et c'est ok au final
on a des entreprises
plutôt be to be
peut-être après l'enfer du ghetto c'est
comme quand par exemple qui est le
google 2
l'équivalent google la recherche
française exactement qui lui par contre
met en avant l' ne peut pas traquer ne
pas aller suivre les internautes comme
un google pourrez plus vous traquer et
respecte un peu plus
la vie privée de
toute cette heure et
ce logiciel a
à qui est aussi la particularité aussi
six ans les différentes langues qu'elle
respecte
santé 34 alors est en passe d'être
encore en breton etc
jean que français
alors de d'une façon plus générale en
dehors du mwc toi ton travail donc
représentant de business france en
espagne
quel est ton rôle et le comment tuer les
entreprises françaises et l'écosystème
français à venir développer son business
ici quand l'espagne alors aurélien moi
ce que je fais ici c'est d'aider les
entreprises
sur la centaine d'entreprises françaises
j'ai accompagné une douzaine
le fme
sur le marché espagnol physiquement et
j'organise des rendez vous
habib touré
des qualités
donc j'ai eu des rendez vous avec j'ai
organisé rendez vous
avec media pro à
qui est le
entreprise qui détient les droits ta kim
gatlin de la liga qui viennent acheter
mes problèmes de la vie des italiennes
et c'est avec telefonica aussi mais
aussi avec vodafone avec mediaset qui le
groupe de télévision
italien qui est présent écrire
st voilà un peu ce contre l'organisme
or avec spécifiquement avec les stars ok
j'ai su faire et plus merci ce que tu
veux te résister non mais c'est un super
salon vous attend bienvenue merci à
l'arrière merci je vous invite à essayer
des commentaires à me dire ce que vous
en pensez est-ce que vous avez d'espèces
vous êtes une start-up parce que ça
pourrait vous intéresser effectivement
de faire appel à business france la
french state pour vous développer à
l'international et notamment pourquoi
pas en espagne est ce que le mwc
pourrait vous intéresser
vous ne marquez tout ça en commentaire
bien évidemment comme d'hab on reste
connectés aux avis année c'est des jolis
coups ça vous abonner parce qu'on va
parler toujours plus d'entreprises
françaises innovantes et de des règles
générales
merci à vous et à très bientôt
j'aimerais bien voir à présent
[Musique]